vous avez un logement mais vous convient
pas mais je veux pas vous laisser tomber
gilbert aimerait bien quitter son
logement insalubre de notre dame de
grâce à montréal mais déménager est
devenu un pensez y bien
c'est un peu difficile continue de mon
revenu dans ce quartier des organismes
communautaires temps d'aider les
locataires qui se retrouvent dans la rue
ou dans des logements insalubres
il ya plusieurs personnes qui n'ont pas
renouvelé leur bail pour le 1er juillet
dans l'espoir de trouver quelque chose
de mieux
ce parce que la famille s'agrandit c'est
justement parce qu'ils y ont une
amélioration mort qui a été dit ou de
leurs revenus qui voulait trouver un
plus grand logement dans leur quartier
et la halle aux grains mi juillet ce fut
impossible pour eux de trouver au québec
une trentaine de familles auront recours
à l'hébergement d'urgence offerts par
les municipalités
mais un nombre beaucoup plus grand de
locataires vont trouver refuge dans leur
famille ou à accepter des logement
inadéquat
la ministre de l'habitation madame
andrée de la forêt est depuis des mois
elle vit dans le déni elle devrait
fusent toujours des reconnaître qu'il ya
une crise du logement non seulement à
montréal mais dans toutes les villes du
québec et elle a réagi trop tard
pourtant il y aurait 15 mille logements
disponibles rien que dans le grand
montréal
mais ils ne sont pas accessibles ou
locataires à faible revenu beaucoup de
propriétaires sont devenus très sélectif
en raison d' expérience avec de mauvais
locataires
tant qu'à avoir des problèmes je montre
mon logement soit vaquin le convertir en
cours d'eau ou même le reprendre pour ma
famille de l'impasse
il va se retirer des logements du marché
sur ne revoit pas les règles l'ancien
gouvernement comme l'actuel refuse de
prendre la mesure de cette réalité l'eau
et m haies mais de les défaire les
investissements requis pour faire du
logement social ce qui est la seule et
unique solution à long terme pour éviter
de nouvelles crises du logement faire
des dépannages d'urgence ne change pas
vraiment la situation du logement des
pénuries sont en train de s'installer de
façon chronique comme c'est déjà le cas
dans plusieurs villes du monde
ici une chaîne marsolais radio canada
montréal